x to the power of two thirds two thirds
now i'm going to give you the man we
already did some work with exit how
cheap at school we did it when it was on
the denominator okay remember that too
what I pulled out if it was it's an even
function it's an even function so
whatever I get on one side I can get on
the other that's really good okay yes
first function Oh Sammy um x equals
sorry y equals x to power to third does
it have any discontinuities are there
any values that break it I can put in 0
0 to the power of 2 30 is still a value
at 0 in fact so I'm there right okay
let's just think about what happens as X
gets bigger so I'm doing this kind of
shape okay and because it's even which
we noticed before it's doing that it has
to it even can we confirm some of this
by getting it's riveted not also missing
funny what's the duty that makes it two
days
kuberan version remix there's that extra
power of negative a third in there right
because I took that and i subtracted one
okay hmm does this fit with what I'm
expecting over here tell me what's
happening as X gets bigger tell me what
happens decrease as X gets bigger even
though it's doing it slowly the
denominator is growing do you agree with
that and it's never going to stop groans
never think nothing stops it ok so this
denominator is going to get really large
will take a while that will get really
large so therefore i'm doing this thing
as well aren't I I'm going to approach
zero over here ok like so what do you
notice mmm cube root of X that appears
here does it it it's an odd function odd
function right just like X cubed is an
odd function so therefore when you start
with negative numbers in here can you
get rid of a negative number sure can
write like say the cube root of negative
27 is negative 3 because it's later
three times that you're three times a
year three the negatives are okay so
therefore even though I'm approaching
here really visible value over here are
I'm gonna be approaching but I'll be
negative right because X is negative so
I'm gonna be doing something like this
you're over that okay last little piece
of information what else can I put on
you that when the when the values of x
it becomes a really really large model
okay um that that goes along with the
other piece with me I was thinking let's
take that if X is very little then the
denominator is very little which means
the whole number is astronomically large
okay don't forget though if it's
negative it's astronomically large and
negative if it's positive astronomically
large and positive okay so i'll bring
that all together and i'm getting a
picture something like this we should
have this is what i was getting to in
order to have that what you're really
describing is asymptotic behavior just
we're not saying there's an attitude we
kind of already need that because
excellent nominator yes so therefore it
can't be equal 0 does this derivative
gel with the graph that we drew yes it
does doesn't it do you see it's not
always an increasing function over here
it's decreasing dropping like a rock
until you get 20 its vertical as well in
fact I I should probably make mine a bit
steeper and then as you transition X is
positive it shifts into increasing
because this guy is positive right if I
go back to my green wave right negative
negative negative positive positive
positive positive okay so by the way one
last little piece what kind of symmetry
you what kind of symmetry okay so we'll
do some formal stuff with their layout
what do we get from all of this okay I'm
these point zero one two three it
happened to all be at the origin because
I chose some really nice easy values for
us these are what we call critical
values okay the important thing you've
been noticing here here here is those
discontinuities in the derivative that's
really the key like discontinuities in
the derivative
some textbooks will also expand this
definition of critical values to include
places where the derivative is zero as
well I think that's really necessary
because we have perfectly fine language
for describing what happens when the
derivative is zero what I call those
station avoidance right like I said that
the definitions not quite as fluid not
quite as rigid so I think this is a
really good way to approach these
different interesting things happen
right so you've got this thing happening
here piecemeal function no surprises
this is not a horizontal put inflection
it's a very cool put in flexion so I
think someone asked about this before
horizontal pay employees implies you can
add vertical that's vertical this thing
is not a point of inflection but
something else interesting happens there
it has its own name it's called a cuss
all right where it has that sort of
sharp cutting sort of bit there right so
these are all different very different
teams right and that's what i mean by
like they all come under this heading
because discontinuities in the
derivative it's like well I don't know
what it is so different things can
happen these are all very different
things but they share this idea in
common hey does that make sense these
critical values like I said when the
textbook talks about it i'm ninety-five
percent sure that particular textbook
you guys are looking at includes when
the derivative is equal to zero that's
fine the question will tell you what to
look for these are the really important
ones but sometimes i'll also say and
include the stationary points in that as
well okay because something interesting
is happening that's all critical needs